2026년 5월 7일 목요일 미국 증시 요약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 혼조세였습니다.
미국과 이란의 합의를 둘러싼 불확실성이 다시 커지면서
유가는 오르고 증시는 하락했습니다.
특히 장중 지정학적 긴장을 높인 소식들이 잇따랐습니다.
월스트리트 저널은 미국이 트럼프 대통령이
프로젝트 프리덤이라고 명명했던 호르무즈 해업 내
고립 선박 호위 작전 재개를 검토하고 있다고 보도했습니다.
이 작전은 앞서 이란과의 무력 충돌 그리고
아랍 에미리티를 겨냥한 미사일 발사로 이어지면서
이번 주 초 잠정 중단된 바 있습니다.
이처럼 불확실성이 고조되는 가운데 장 마감을 한 시가량 앞두고
이란 현지 매체들은 호르무즈 해업 인근에서
폭발음이 들렸다고 잇따라 보도했습니다.
이와 관련해 미 중부사령부는 호르무즈 해업을 지나
오만만으로 향하던 미 해군 구축함 세척이
이란의 미사일과 드론, 소형 보트의 공격을 받았고
이에 대응 차원에서 공격을 가담한 이란 측 시설을 타격했다고 밝혔습니다.
다만 이번 사태가 전면전으로 확대되는 것은 아니라고 선을 그었습니다.
S&P500 지수는 0.38% 하락 마감했습니다.
인텔과 AMD 등 반드 최주가 약세를 보이며 지수 하락을 주도한 반면
데이터독은 연간 실적 전망치를 상향 조정한 후
주가가 31% 폭등하며
소프트웨어 업종의 랠리를 견인했습니다.
경제 지표 측면에서는 고용시장의 견주함이 재확인되었습니다.
주간 신규 실업상 청구 건수가 지난주 대비 소폭 반등하긴 했으나
대규모 해군은 여전히 제한적임을 시사했습니다.
이처럼 탄탄한 노동시장과 높은 에너지 가격이 유지되면서
투자자들은 미 연준이 연말까지 금리를 동결할 것이라는 전망에 무게를 싣고 있습니다.
클리브랜드 여는 헤멧 총재 역시
대내외 부동산 시장과 에너지 가격이 유지되면서
불확실성이 큰 상황인 만큼 연준이 상당기간 금리를 동결할 것을 예상한다고 밝히며
이러한 관측을 뒷받침했습니다.
시티그룹의 맥슬레이터는
전쟁 종식을 위한 합의 여부가 명확해질 때까지
유가는 계속해서 극심한 변동성을 보일 것이다.
에드워드 존스의 모나마아자는
투자자들이 지속되는 지적적 불확실성을 마주하고 있지만
호주를 보이는 기업 실적과 한탄한 경제 펀더멘털이
증시를 보이고 있습니다.
든든하게 뒷받침하고 있다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 8일 금요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제 지표는
22시 30분 미국 4월 비농업 취업자 수
22시 30분 미국 4월 실업률
23시 미국 5월 미시간대 소비자 심리지수
23시 미국 5월 미시간대 기대인플레이션
23시 미국 3월 도매 판매
22시 미국 베이커 유주 총 시축일수가 예정되어 있습니다.